Let's get into audience questions for the
week, our first host.
Trump set of questions in the Joe Biden era.
There's something in the air that's just seeming
a little different, but let's get right into
it.
And a lot of these questions really go to
sort of seeking to understand where we are
as a country right now.
And I think that these all tie together very
well.
The first one is David.
Now, with Trump in the rear view, how did
Trump change the country and how did he not?
And I think this is really the perfect question
to start to understand what happened.
Donald Trump did not, as as near as I can
tell, create racists or racism, create xenophobes
who want to stop immigration from so-called
asshole countries.
What he did was he coalesced these groups
of people and he made them more comfortable
being public about it.
The things that used to be whispered behind
closed doors by people who had some sense
that while this is what I believe, I recognize
I'll probably be looked down upon in most
circles if I say it out loud.
They were welcomed into saying these things
out loud.
But it's important to understand that that
is a change.
Not not creating racism may be an area where
there was not a change under Trump, but the
racism being more open is a change under Donald
Trump.
And along those lines, the changes we really
saw under Trump include, of course, degrading
the public discourse, degrading what counts
as acceptable political debate, and what counts
as acceptable in a political campaign in terms
of particular types of insults, not only about
your political opponents, but, you know, ridiculing
disabilities, ridiculing deceased members
of the military.
There was nothing beyond the pale.
It was beyond the pale that there was nothing
that Trump saw as off the table.
I think better said in terms of what and how
you can criticize others and the change Trump
made.
And we'll see if it gets changed again.
But it could be an irreversible change.
Trump removed whatever was left of the idea
of American exceptionalism.
We really sucked during the last four years
in ways that many Americans wrongly but many
Americans previously thought would only happen
in other countries or only happened in other
countries.
And it turns out that what we learned is that
the United States is just like any other place,
really terrible, corrupt people can get into
power, that corruption and weaponization can
get into law enforcement, it can get into
the military.
It can get into all aspects of government.
It can interfere with science.
It can infect even, you know, NASA and all
of these other things.
And that is a change.
Now, the things that didn't change during
Trump's presidency are also cause for concern.
What do I mean by that?
Well, how did Trump get to be the Republican
nominee and ultimately become president?
The structure of anti intellectual ism and
reactionary politics, not based, in fact,
are partially what got Donald Trump into power.
That hasn't changed is in fact, I would argue
it's worse than ever.
And it's been particularly weaponized by the
explosion of right wing extreme media like
Newsmax and on and Funen stuff and others.
The Electoral College got Trump into power.
That hasn't changed.
So another Trump could come into power again.
I think if there is, what is the most important
message that could be taken away from the
Trump presidency?
Because there are many checks and balances
aren't nearly as robust as we thought they
were.
When you have a madman in the White House
and know we have all these different takeaways.
The most important takeaway now that we're
looking forward must be nothing has changed
about what got Trump into power in the first
place.
If anything, it's worse, as we saw by 75 million
people voting for Trump in November.
And just as easily as Trump got in, I would
argue it is even easier for another Trump
to get into power.
That's the top takeaway.
So, yes, fixed gerrymandering, get rid of
the Electoral College, find a way to democratize
the Senate, which is so anti-democratic, you've
got to deal with campaign finance, put dealing
with climate into the law rather than leaving
it to the whims of political administrations.
There's such a long list of things that have
to be done.
But if we don't recognize that until we actually
deal with the culture that got Trump into
a position where he could win the Republican
primary and eventually to the presidency,
it could happen again.
And that's very, very scary.